hi this is pressure Locker the movie
Mean Girls featured a number of math
questions in this video I'll present
each question and then I'll go over how
you could solve each one the first
question in the math competition is up
on the screen I'm going to enlarge this
question twice the larger of two numbers
is three more than five times the
smaller and the sum of four times the
larger and three times the smaller is 71
what are the numbers the second question
was also put up on the screen I'm just
going to present the text there was no
image in the movie find an odd
three-digit number whose digits add up
to 12 the digits are all different and
the difference between the first two
digits equals the difference between
someone buzzed in and gave the answer
probably the rest of the question was
the difference between the last two
digits now I'm going to present the
third and most famous of the math
questions from the movie evaluate the
limit as X goes to 0 of the quantity the
natural log of 1 minus X minus the sine
of X all over 1 minus the cosine squared
of X all right so those are the
questions now let's go over how you
could solve each one let's consider the
first question we have a word problem
that relates two different variables x
and y so let's imagine we have X which
is smaller than the number Y twice the
larger of two numbers two times y is
equal to three more than five times the
smaller number X so that's one equation
the other equation is four times the
larger for Y and three times the smaller
3x is equal to 71 we now a series of two
equations in two variables we can solve
this by eliminating one of the variables
and then solving for the other so
let's eliminate the Y by multiplying the
top equation by two so we have four y
equals six plus 10x we can eliminate the
4y by subtracting the second equation so
we're going to eliminate the 4y and then
we end up with negative 3x equals
negative 65 plus 10x well group the X's
over to one side and then we can solve
that X is equal to five we'll use one of
our equations that we'd already started
with and then get that y is equal to 14
so this question is not too difficult
but in this math competition you would
have to solve it very quickly the second
question is more interesting find an odd
three-digit number whose digits add up
to 12 so a three-digit number x y&z we
can think about is 100x plus 10y plus Z
so we want to add the sum of the digits
that's saying X plus y plus Z is equal
to 12 the second part of the question is
that the difference between the first
two digits x and y so X minus y is equal
to the difference between the next two
digits which is y and C so in the movie
they give an answer of 741 but actually
there's not enough information to solve
this question because although 741 does
satisfy these constraints
you also have 543 which is another odd
digit number whose digits add up to 12
and the difference between the first two
is the same as the difference between
the second tube so it's actually lucky
maybe they cut it out in the movie that
741 was the correct answer but just from
what we've heard in the movie we
couldn't actually figure it out so now
let's consider the third question let's
evaluate this limit if you substitute in
if you just try and substitute an X in
the numerator and the denominator
you get an indeterminate form of 0/0 so
this limit is not easy to calculate just
by substitution we're going to have is
to simplify this a little bit
so let's simplify the denominator that
one minus cosine of square one minus
cosine squared of X is equal to sine
squared of X this is still an
indeterminate form we really can't
divide through or simplify but we what
we can do is we'll use a trick we're
going to look at the power series
approximation of each term around zero
this is a common trick that they use in
physics we don't use it in mathematics
as much but in this particular problem
it can be very useful the term natural
log of 1 minus X is very very close to
negative X when you look around 0
similarly sine of X is almost equal to X
around 0 and sine squared of X will be
almost x squared these are very good
approximations as X gets close to zero
so when we look at the limit as X goes
to 0 we can use these approximations to
consider what the limit might be when we
substitute these in we're essentially
looking for the limit of negative x
minus x divided by x squared this
simplifies to negative 2 over X and the
graph of this looks roughly like this
following figure and when you consider
the limit as X goes to 0 we actually
find out the limit does not exist
because as we approach from the negative
side we go to positive infinity and as
we go from the positive numbers we go to
negative infinity so the correct answer
to this question which is presented in
the movie is the limit does not exist
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can also catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and if you like
this video please check out my books
there's link in the video description